j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public nouveau rendez-vous qu'on vous
propose tous les 15 jours jusqu'au 9
juin date des élections européennes que
fait l'Europe on pose cette question
simple sur des thématiques l'énergie
c'était il y a 15 jours l'immigration on
y viendra la gestion de crise la
transparence et ce soir la transition
écologique avec ce Green Deal souvent
montré du doigt par les agriculteurs en
colère ce pacte vert ambitieux et ne
concerne pas seulement notre
alimentation l'objectif vous le savez
c'est d'atteindre la neutralité carbone
en 2050 Fabien REER c'était en septembre
dernier dans son discours sur l'état de
l'Union
ursela van derlen défendait sa feuille
de route sur le Green Deal un pacte vert
pour l'Europe qui a déjà subi quelques
vents
contrair nous restons ambitieux et
fidèles à notre stratégie de croissance
né en 2019 dans la foulée des marches
pour le climat le Green Deal est un
ensemble de réformes sur la transition
écologique pour atteindre la neutralité
climatique de l'Europe en
2050 parmi les principales mesures déjà
adoptées le doublement de la part des
énergies renouvelables dans notre mix
énergétique l'interdiction de la vente
de véhicules thermiques en 2035 ou
l'instauration d'une taxe carbone aux
frontières de l'UE sur l'importation de
produits ou matières premières qui
pollue donc c'est une grande série de
réformes qui vise à s'attaquer aux
émissions de gaz à effet de ser dans
tous les secteurs de l'économie
européenne le transport le bâtiment
l'industrie énergie et qui vraiment fait
une accélération sans précédent de la
transition écologique à l'échelle du
continent mais certaines mesures ont été
mis en suspens voire retiré du Green
Deal comme la réduction de moitié des
pesticides dans l'UE d'ici 2030
abandonné face à la colère des
agriculteurs ou encore un texte sur la
biodiversité vidé de sa substance par
les eurodéputés conservateurs à
l'approche des élections européennes
droite et extrême droite réclam une
pause sur le deal un jeu dangereux
analyse cet expert il y a une course
mondiale à la transition écologique qui
est enclenchée la Chine est en train de
prendre énormément d'avances pour
devenir l'usine mondiale de la
transition écologique les États-Unis
avec des investissements massifs sont en
train de rattraper leur retard si
l'Europe s'arrête à ce stadelà on risque
très rapidement d'être déclassé pour
rendre le pacte vert plus acceptable
auprès des agriculteurs et des ménages
la Commission européenne a adopté un
fond de 17,5 milliard d'euros des
financements pour limiter les
conséquences sociales de la transition
écologique que fait l'Europe en matière
de transition écologique le pacte vert
est-il trop ambitieux on en débat avec
Camille deard bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes chef du centre énergie de
l'Institut Jacques Delor chercheuse en
politique européenne de l'énergie
annecler Poirier bonsoir et bienvenue
journaliste indépendant spécialisé en
dans les questions de transition
énergétique notamment pour vers le média
éedard linge bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes professeur d'histoire contemporaine
à à l'Université Lumière Lyon 2 membre
du laboratoire d'études rurales et
spécialiste de l'histoire de la
paysannerie française au 20e siècle ett
Tran Nui éditorialiste politique est
resté à mes côtés on on on va parler pas
mal d'agriculture mais d'abord une
question générale paril faut on l'a dit
là dans le sujet le pacte vert c'est ça
va bien au-delà de l'agriculture Camille
dear est-ce qu'il produit déjà ce pacte
vert parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
décisions ces derni années notamment sur
l'énergie les transport et cetera est-ce
qu' produit déjà des effets positifs
réel alors les effets positifs de la
transition énergétique c'est plutôt le
résultat des efforts passés des efforts
de ces 10 dernières années au moins on a
vu le déploiement record du de l'éolien
et du solaire cette année encore le
pacte vert européen il a été négocié à
Bruxelles donc c'est le les
États-membres et le Parlement européen
qui se sont mis d'accord sur les
principales mesures elles vont
maintenant redescendre au niveau des
États-membres qui doivent soit
accompagner la mise en œuvre de ces
nouvelles mesures soit les mettre en
œuvre eux-mêm oui mais si on prend par
exemple l'automobile euh la la fin de la
vente de voitures thermiquees neu en
2035 bah ça a eu un effet quasi immédiat
puisque les l'industrie auto s est si
peut-être contrainté forcé mais à à
prise virage c'est très juste et c'est
vrai que c'est le principal message
qu'on peut qu'on peut retenir de ce
pacte vert à ce stade c'est un un signal
de marché qui est envoyé aux acteurs qu'
soit public ou privé ainsi que les
citoyens de se préparer au changement à
venir ouais ancla pourer justement je
reste sur l'automobile à quel point ça a
bouleversé peut-être d'ailleurs
fragilisé l'industrie automobile
européenne cette décision de cette
perspective d'interdiction des voiture
termique neu euh je je je suis pas sûr
que ça ait fragilisé l'industrie
automobile au contraire on lui laisse 15
ans pour se préparer c'est d'ailleurs un
mouvement qui avait déjà été enclenché
et je pense que c'est c'est important de
donner de la visibilité à l'industrie le
le le commissaire au climat l'a encore
dit hier lorsqu'ils ont présenté la
phase 2 du Green Deal c'est important de
laisser l'industrie européenne se
préparer d' d'utant plus qu'elle est pas
seule sur le la compétition mondiale en
fait et ce serait vraiment dommage dis
fragilisé parce que les automobiles
chinoises électriqu elles sont elles ont
pas attendu elles sont moins cherres
elles arrivent donc donc donc il y a
quand même une petite fragilisation de
l'industrie automobile européenne je
sais pas en fait on est en train de
mettre en place effectivement ce sera un
des gros enjeux d'ailleurs de la
prochaine mandature des des des éléments
pour pouvoir justement favoriser
l'industrie européenne par comme vous
dites il y a pas de raison qu'on qu'on
achète des voitures exclusivement venant
d'Asie euh ça va être une des grosses
questions du prochain du la prochaine
mandature est-ce qu'on arrive à être à
la hauteur en terme de
réindustrialisation notamment de ce qui
est fait en Chine évidemment mais aux
États-Unis avec l'inflation reduction
Act en Inde aussi en fait tout tous les
pays s'y mettent donc il y a pas de
raison que l'Europe ne protège pas son
vouz intervenir oui je pense que c'est
un point important c ce signal qui a été
envoyé qui a été assez critiqué par les
conservateurs européens et l'industrie
automobile européenne qui pourtant doit
prendre ce tournant qu'il y ait cette
interdiction ou non parce qu'aujourd'hui
les ventes de véhicules électriques
chinois ont dépassé les exportations
allemandes qui est le vrai la vraie
usine européenne donc on voit aussi ici
que ne pas prendre ce tournant de
l'électrique pour l'industrie automobile
européenne c'est un signe de déclin qui
pourrait être irrémédiable donc vous
nous dites on aurait été battu un jour
ou l'autre si on l'avaitre B j'entends
j'entends cette cet argument alors
justement c'est intéressant parce que
l'ambition ou la brutalité on peut
employer les deux
termes de ce virage sur l'autom
bon vous l'avez dit certains le
remettent en question certains disent
qu'il faut assouplir ses règles que
finalement ce sera pas exactement
appliqué comme ça est-ce que Edward
Linch les les agriculteurs européens là
ce qui est en train de se passer depuis
plusieurs semaines ont pas justement
tiré les leçons de de de ce qui s'est
passé pour l'automobile sur le sur le
mode mobilisons-nous face au pacte vert
avant qu'il soit complètement trop tard
voyez ce que je veux dire je je je pense
que c'est pas aussi c'est pas aussi
pensé je pense qu'on est sur un train de
plus long hein de d'opposition en tout
cas de de de grande méfiance par rapport
à à à l'impact et à à la mise en place
de mesures contraignantes en terme
d'environnement donc je je pense que
c'est davantage un voilà un effet de de
circonstan hein parce que les les
mouvements sociaux ils sont aussi portés
par des effets de conjoncture des effets
de de dégradation des revenus dans
certaines catégories et voilà et donc du
coup le le le est très hétérogène ce ce
mouvement européen mais le point commun
ou le petit le plus petit dénominateur
commun che pas quel terme employer c'est
peut-être justement cet appel à freiner
le le virage écologique on on peut se
poser la question en fait je pense parce
que quand on regarde les mouvements on
voit que la question du revenu qui qui a
toujours été une question fondamentale
pour les les
agriculteurs elle est quand même très
présente et que parmi les mesures qui
ont été prises les mesures les plus
immédiates c'est celles sur le Gasol et
on voit en Italie aujourd'hui qui était
pas rentré dans la bataille les
agriculteurs italiens bah ils ont vu que
dans tous les pays on supprimit les
taxes sur le gaz o ils ont dit mais nous
aussi alors et hop ils y sont mis donc
euh voilà après il y a il y a quand même
sans doute aussi une forme peut-être
d'instrumentalisation de de la
mobilisation par des état-majors
syndicaux je pense en particulier à
FNSEA pour qui effectivement ça permet
de faire monter en puissance l'agenda
environnemental qui est pas forcément la
préoccupation première des agriculteurs
dans leur quotidien oui alors ça on y
reviendra puis alors ça là c'est franon
français mais euh sur le le le gazol
justement et le gazol non routier ben
tiens qu'est-ce qui est en train de se
passer en en ce moment dans plusieurs
villes de France c'est des artisans des
travaux publics qui bloquent des dépôts
prétoliers voilà ça s'est passé à Brest
aujourd'hui et puis c'était dans dans
une autre ville que je recherche que je
retrouve pas les c'est l'Orient l'Orient
il il y a quelques jours bon je sais pas
quelle importance ça prendra mais il
réclame pour eux la même mesure que
celle dont on bénéficient les
agriculteurs je reviens au au pacte vert
et à l'ambition on va dire
environnementale de l'Europe que fait
l'Europe en matière de transformation
environnementale cet objectif qui a été
annoncé 2040 l'Europe veut avoir baissé
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
90 % par rapport à l'année de référence
qui est
1990 Camille dear déjà c'est de de quoi
on parle c'est un un objectif c'est une
ambition et puis la deuxième partie de
la question c'est est-ce que cette
ambition est réaliste oui alors c'est
d'abord c'est un objectif c'est un
objectif qui est prévu par la première
loi climat européenne qui a été adoptée
en 2021 et qui met l'objectif
contraignant pour l'UE d'atindre la
neutralité climat en 2050 et un objectif
de - 55 % en 2030 donc cet objectif de
90 % il va être débattu au sein du
conseil au sein du Parlement et devrait
devenir contraignant la deuxième la
deuxième chose la deème partie de votre
question qui était sur que réaliste
est-ce que c'est réaliste et bien en
réalité oui parce que si on suit la
trajectoire actuelle si on met en œuvre
les nouvelles lois qui ont été adoptées
au niveau européen qu'on se met sur la
trajectoire des - 55 % d'ici 2030 en
réalité on atteindrait moin 88 % en 2040
donc en réalité c'est totalement
réaliste pourvu que nous mettions tout
en œuvre pour se conformer à ces
objectifs de 2030 c'est que l'objectif
pardon de 2040 vient remplacer celui de
2030 donc ça éloigne la
perspectiveou ça dans une même
trajectoire exactement voilà c'est des
un escalier qu'on doit monter jusqu'à
neutralité carbone en 2050 en fait mais
d'ailleurs 55% vous avez peut-être
répondu détail mais je tout vous dire on
est en train de me parler dans l'oreer
donc j'ai pas pu tout bien entendre mais
est-ce que moin 50 % 55 % 2030 c'est
tenable là est-ce qu'on est vers cette
trajectoire je je vous pose la question
à vous hier euh alors ça j'ai envie de
dire ça dépend des secteurs he fin on
change rien si on prend les voilà les
mesures qui ont été adoptées si on les
applique est-ce que on atteint les 55
déjà il est pas du tout question de ne
rien changer hein s s' y a bien quelque
chose sur lequel il y a consensus au
niveau scientifique c'est qu'il est pas
du tout ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit si on
applique les mesures qui ont déjà été D
appque les mesures qui ont déjà été
prises dans certains secteurs et
notamment celui de de l'énergie on est
vraiment sur une bonne voie alors
l'Union européenne s'est engagé à
doubler la part des énergies
renouvelables dans sa consommation
énergétique finale d'ici 2030 donc c'est
dans 7 ans on est à 20 % faudrait passer
à 42 et5i % il se trouve que la
dynamique est massive on y sera on y
sera bon peut-être pas mais si on y est
pas c'est à quelques points près il y a
vraiment une dynamique qui s'enclenche
je veux dire les objectifs ont un effet
un peu déjà un tout petit peu
autoréalisateur sur les industries qui
se qui se mettent en marche quand même
oui oui il y a beaucoup d'industries
beaucoup d'entreprises qui prennent ce
ce virage et effectivement l'aiguillon
réglementaire joue un rôle sauf que là
on sort d'une période où il y a eu un
une une réaction plus ou moins
épidermique plus ou moins pensée plus ou
moins de long terme vous nous l'avez dit
Douard Lynch celle des des agriculteurs
à quel point cette feuille de route
climatique elle les impacte eux aussi B
pour l'instant je je pense qu'ell ne les
impacte pas il y a pas de mesures
concrètes qui sont mis en place hein
ete l'un des facteurs de
mécontentement à l'automne des des des
des agriculteurs c'était davantage des
problèmes de ver de de non verersement
des primes européennes donc des des des
modèles de de réorientation des primes
et cetera donc on n'est pas du tout dans
dans dans dans la réalité d'une
contrainte environnementale très forte
on revient à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur des questions qui sont des
questions de filière euh d'un secteur
voilà extrêmement extrêmement sensible à
des à des à des variations de de
conjoncture le gouvernement l'Europe il
répondent à côté lorsque du coup ils
freaîent sur les pesticides ou écopyo
bah disons qu'ils répondent ils
répondent que que que que faiblement au
au problèmes des agriculteurs ça on y
reviendra un peu plus tard si vousz si
vous voulez bien parce que c'est un vrai
chapitre important le le le coup de
frein annoncé par Ura van derlen mais
justement on emploie ces expressions le
coup de frein la pose faire une pause en
matière de de normees environnemental
bah c'est exactement ce que disait
Emmanuel Macron pas il y a il y a une
semaine ou il y a 15 jours c'était le 11
mai dernier c'est le jour où il dévoile
sa stratégie pour accélérer la
réindustrialisation de la France et il
dit ceci moi j'appelle à la pause
règlementaire européenne maintenant il
faut qu'on exécute il faut pas qu'on
fasse de nouveaux changements de règles
parce qu'on va perdre tous les acteurs
donc on a besoin de stabilité maintenant
faut accélérer sur les déploiements
parce que sinon le risque concourt c'est
au fond d'être les mieux disants en
termes de réglementation et les moins
disants en termees de financement
Camille de est-ce que le président
français donc c'était il y a il y a 7 7
ou 8 mois a été entendu en partie par
par ses partenaires européens alors oui
totalement pour le pire et le meilleur
j'ai envie de dire dans le sens où
effectivement on a eu une très forte
activité réglementaire au niveau
européen quiil va falloir mettre en
œuvre et ça va demander des financements
et ça c'est très important de le
souligner et c'est une une question qui
est assez mal partie euh à Bruxelles euh
et c'est un des grands enjeux des
élections européennes et même de la
prochaine commission comment est-ce
qu'on finance cette ambition climatique
de manière à préserver la cohésion
sociale et la compétitivité européenne
et cet enjeu de compétitivité et même de
résilience de l'économie européenne elle
va nécessiter de nouvelles normes on a
aujourd'hui des besoins d'accroître la
circularité de notre économie on a
besoin de soutenir les agriculteurs vers
ces nouvelles normes et c'est très
important aujourd'hui que les acteurs
qui sont qui seront majoritaires au
Parlement européen garde cette position
constructive par rapport au pacte vert
et euh reste voilà euh dans dans une
démarche d'amélioration de ce des outils
qui nous manquent pour réaliser cette
ambition alors il a il y a deux éléments
très importants et qu'on va aborder dans
ce débat la question du financement euh
ça on y reviendra mais il y a
effectivement la question et moi je vais
employé le terme d'acceptabilité
d'accompagnement social d'acceptabilité
du de de de la transformation
environnementale alors autour de cette
table on est tous d'accord moi le
premier que ce virage il faut le prendre
que on le prend déjà trop tard et que
c'est parce qu'on le prend trop tard que
on a ses difficultés et et et ces coup
de frein demandés par par certains de de
nos concitoyens ici en France ou en
Europe mais quand même quand même
unclair Poirier il y a aussi la question
on l'a ébordé dans dans notre premier
débat de du décalage
entre les élites une une administration
français européennes est ce que vivent
les Français ou les Européens dans leur
quotidien est-ce qu'on n'est pas au cœur
de débat et est-ce que l'Europe doit pas
tenir compte de cette colère agricole
pour changer une partie de cette
méthodes je c'est pas évident le projet
européen il est forcément un petit peu
loin des citoyens je veux dire on on
décide à 27 de lois qui sont transposé
parfois 2 ans plus tard dans les pays
ouis vous dit parce que si on change
rien c'est c'est c'est peut-être pas les
plus constructifs ou ceux qui veulent
justement un virage environnemental qui
vont qui vont être majoritaires dans
dans 4 mois au Parlement européen je
suis pas sûr que le problème
viennent de enfin du du projet européen
en tant que tel ce qui par contre ce qui
me semble clair et dans l'acceptabilité
du du projet dont vous parliez c'est que
l'Europe elle a pris un virage vert
c'est assez indéniable est-ce qu'elle a
pris un virage social c'est pas encore
sûr et le vrai risque en fait c'est que
c'estes ces objectifs verts qui ont été
pris et validés c'est le risque c'est
qu'il crée des inégalités et ça c'est
des bombes à retardement en fait et donc
le le le la phase là qui s'ouvre et
c'est c'est presque la plus importante
ça va être celle de soigner le volet
social le volet industriel pour
justement en fait qui n'accepterait pas
d'engager une transition écologique si
elle est bien financée si elle est juste
si elle si elle est équitable en fait
oui je suis d'accord avec vous et si
elle est compréhensible parce que dans
les critiques de des agriculteurs Edward
Linch il y a aussi les on revient aux
normes il y a aussi les normes
contradictoires les injonctions
contradictoires et c'est aussi leur
réalité on peut leur donner crédit de ça
oui bien sûr mais je pense que c'est un
un mot
X de de de toutes les sociétés euh euh
contemporaine et euh de plus en plus
complexe voilà de plus en plus complexe
avec des régulations de plus en plus
complexes donc je je suis pas sûr que ça
soit un un motif de voilà qui soit qui
soit suffisant pour justifier euh
l'arrêt ou le manque on est on est déjà
au niveau des des pays dans des
situations complexes c'est pas on a pas
besoin de l'Europe pour faire la
paperacee hein c'est c'est de la
complexité administrative on est même
assez fort je pense nationalement voilà
donc je pense c'est un peu faire un
mauvais procès à l'Europe c'est une
façon je peux faire je peux poser la
même question sur l'administration
française hein oui oui non mais c'est
que de que du coup de de penser que le
voilà forcément on rajoute un échelon
supplémentaire donc on rajoute un seuil
de norme donc et on on rajoute de la
complexité voilà après je je pense pas
que ça ça soit arrêter ne changera rien
en fait
problè mieux mieux accompagner et
peut-être bien sr plus associer ceux qui
sont sur le terrain à la prise de
décision pour que ils nous disent pas 3
mois après ou 2 ans après parce que le
temps que la norme européenne finisse
par être appliquée ben pardon mais c'est
absurde ça a été pensé par des gens qui
savent pas ce qui est notre métier enfin
voilà je je me fais le le porte-parole
en quelque sorte mais c'est ce qu'on a
entendu sur les barrages si on prend
l'exemple par exemple de l'agriculture
l'agriculture est un secteur qui qui est
qui est encadré par l'Europe depuis depu
depuis 40 ans dire quand on a mis en
place les cotas laitiers et qu'on les a
géré pendant 30 ans il y en a eu de de
la complexité administrative c'était
c'était terrifiant personne ne compr
encore comment ça marchait heureusement
ça a disparu donc voilà on découvre pas
tout d'un coup que l'Europe c'est
compliqué ce sont voilà il il y a ces
enjeux là je question peut-être de
gouvernance Camille Defar est-ce que
cette enfin voilà cette crise reste sur
la crise agricole mais qui pose ces
questions je viens d'évoquer ça ça
intègre justement cette l de question la
gouvernance européenne non je pense que
vous avez raison de parler de la façon
des méthodes de l'Union européenne et
même de la façon dont les processus
administratifs européens sont mis en
œuvre il y a un besoin de simplification
des processus administratifs qui soi au
niveau local national et européen en
réalité pour rendre cette transition
facile pour tous les acteurs parce que
c'est une transition qui va être
difficile qui requiert des efforts de
tout le monde et effectivement il y a
cette question de cohérence qui est très
importante et aujourd'hui on souffre
aussi au niveau européen comme au niveau
national d'un manque de représentativité
ou d'un manque d'inclusion de tous les
acteurs qui sont concernés or le
problème c'est que cette transition elle
va concerner tous les secteurs tous les
acteurs à tous les niveaux et depuis
notre salle de bain jusqu'à la
Commission européenne donc on a des
enjeux très très concrets qui doivent
être anticipés néanmoins cette
transition on n jamais fait une
transition aussi rapide aussi profonde
de toute la structure de notre économie
donc il va falloir être aussi humble
dans le sens où on va faire des erreurs
de politique publique mais il faut avoir
la confiance dans nos institutions pour
savoir rectifier ces erreurs au fur et à
mesure mais d'ailleurs est-ce que enfin
il il faut forcément l'chelon européen
parce qu'il y a besoin de la puissance
européenne et notamment de la puissance
financière on y reviendra sur la
question du euh justement des des moyens
du financement un emprunt ou pas mais
euh une une transformation
environnementale efficace est-ce qu'elle
est pas forcément pointilliste à un
moment d' parce que la solution à Brest
c'est pas la même que la solution à
Hambourg et peut-être même que la
solution à Brest c'est pas la même que
la solution à Perpignan
ou mais je pense que prendre des
décisions à l'échelle européenne
n'empêche pas du tout de de de décliner
par échelon bien au contraire par contre
c'est vrai que ça me fait penser au
mouvement agricole euh et ça ça a été
une de une des une des une des choses
qui a été portée c'est qu'actuellement
les agriculteurs se en Europe se font
concurrence entre entre pays et donc on
voit bien qu'une des réponses à ça c'est
pas moins d'Europe c'est plus d'Europe
plus plus d'harmonisation pour qu'en
fait ils ils aient tous les mêmes
contraintes et et et aussi on espère les
mêmes aides en fait alors on va revenir
maintenant on a commencé à à l'évoquer
mais euh sur ce que le pacte vert le
Green Deal prévoit ou prévoyait plutôt
en matière agricole il y avait euh
plusieurs idé notamment réduire de 50 %
l'utilisation des pesticides d'ici à
2030 augmenter la biodiversité dans les
écosystèmes agricole ou exploiter 25 %
des terres agricoles en bio d'ici à 2030
on va voir tout de suite avec Audrey
vetas que il y a eu un coup de frein
annoncé après ce mouvement cette colère
des des agriculteurs qui a poussé
bonsoir audre la Commission européenne à
faire en partie marche arrière oui on
peut dire que c'est un un revers pour le
pacte vert et tout s'est accéléré ces
derniers jours face à la colère des
agriculteurs la Commission européenne a
proposé en début de semaine de retirer
l'un des textes les plus important de ce
Green Deal il y en a plusieurs mais l'un
des textes les plus importants qui
visait à réduire de moitié l'usage des
pesticides dans l'Union
européenne la Commission a proposé de
réduire les risques liés aux produits
chimiques phytopharmaceutique dans un
but louable mais elle est devenue un
symbole de polarisation il faut donc
faire quelque chose et c'est pourquoi je
proposerai au collège de retirer cette
proposition alors pour être tout à fait
honnête il faut dire que ce texte était
plutôt malengagé parce qu'il a été
étudié cet automne au Parlement européen
il a été rejeté certains députés
considérait qu'il allait trop loin
d'autres pas assez et c'était pas
forcément mieux du côté des
États-membres qui doivent aussi étudier
le texte de leur côté et qui n'avançait
pas beaucoup finalement la Commission
européenne a donné un gage aux
agriculteurs en abandonnant un texte qui
était déjà mal avancé qui se qui s'en
lisait est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
pas le seul coup de canif donné à ce
pacte vert non et pour ça il fallait
écouter la suite du discours d'oursoua
vanterlayen mardi elle a affirmé que
tous les textes qui ont été adoptés
permettront à l'Union européenne de
réduire ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'environ 90 % d'ici 2040 par
rapport à celle enregistrée en 90 année
de référence mais elle a pas fait de
préconisation supplémentaire en clair on
continue sans en faire plus et on y
arrivera sauf que que d'après les
observateurs c'est une affirmation très
optimiste qui s'appuie sur le fait que
ce qui a été mis en place va être
accepté et va réussir un peu trop rose
pour être honnête je vais vous montrer
une réaction d'une représentante de
Greenpeace Sylvia Pastorelli après
l'intervention de la présidente de la
Commission européenne et voici ce
qu'elle dit c'est comme vouloir éviter
un cancer de la langue sans prévoir
d'arrêter de fumer en fait oursoua
venderlen elle joue un jeu compliqué
parce qu'elle doit défendre le Green
Deal qui est un marqueur de son mandat
qu'elle porte depuis 2019 et en même
temps elle appartient à un groupe
politique le PPE qui est la droite
conservatrice elle doit le préserver
sauf que le PPE bah lui il tire à boulet
rouge sur ce pacte vert merci beaucoup
je signal que vous signez un podcast
s'appelle trade d'union exaement voilà
sur avec un épisode sur le Green Deal
partvec un épisode sur le Green Deal en
partenariat donc c'était le bon moment
pour le dire c'est en partenariat avec
notre chaîne merci beaucoup encore une
fois audre je je reviens vers vous
anclair Poirier peut-être sur pour
analyser un peu cette décision de la
présidente de la Commission européenne
Ursula vanonder derlen on l'analyse en
regardeant le calendrier tout simplement
on est à 4 mois des élections
européennes elle fait de la politique on
peut dire ça comme ça ouais ça ça date
d'un tout petit peu plus loin
malheureusement en fait la VLAN elle a
été très courageuse en début de mandat
elle a vraiment forcé la droite sont
partis à à faire corps derrière elle
pour le Green Deal en début de mandat on
a eu une union sacrée derrière le Green
Deal et puis ça s'est assez vite
essoufflé certains disent que démiandat
la droite a commencé à regarder vers
l'extrême droite en fait ça s'est
concrétisé sur les mesures agricoles
et et en fait non ça ça ça remonte déjà
un tout petit peu en effet là il y a son
élection il y a les élections
européennes son élection à elle qui se j
elle est le plus prudente possible elle
essaie de garder la droite avec elle
elle essaie de garder l'industrie et
donc elle est dans une position très
délicate parce qu'à la fois elle porte
le Green Deal elle veut que ça se
poursuive mais elle a un parti
effectivement qui est en train de lâcher
qui regarde de plus en plus vers
l'extrême droite sur ses sujet ARD l
comment vous l'analysez vous cette cette
annonce de d'Ursula van derlen pourquoi
elle cède aux agriculs je simplifie mais
volontairement de de la exactement de la
même manière hein c'est-à-dire que les
les agriculteurs dans leur chacun dans
leur pays font pression efficacement sur
leur gouvernement pour la axi dans une
perspective très clairement
électoraliste parce que même si les
élections europées sont européennes on
sait bien que les les les chaque pays
regarde ses propres élections
européennes de son point de vue
politique et donc voilà on a un
phénomène de relais un phénomène
culbutau malheureux qui qui
effectivement va je suis tout à fait
d'accord mais qui correspond aussi
finalement si on le remet dans le dans
le le l'espace national à à la manière
dont dont dont Emmanuel Macron engagé au
départ sur des grandes ambitions
écologiques prêt à tout transformer le
monde ben voilà c'est réit sur ses
positions au fur à mesure que son son
positionnement politique dérivait vers
la droite çaf me semble assez simple à
comprendre et puis peut-être les les les
ces enjeux environnementaux ils sont un
peu moins populaires aujourd'hui ou plus
difficiles à porter politique c'est ce
que vous avez dit comme il est loin le
temps des des grands slogans du make our
planet great again quand Emmanuel Macron
se faisait donc sacré champion de la
terre le temps des grandes marches pour
le climat celui où grettenberg
apparaissait comme nobélisable et avait
droit à la tribune d'honneur à
l'Assemblée nationale c'était il y a pas
si longtemps bon c'était plus sans doute
un affichage politique que réellement
des actes notamment au niveau de la
France on a encore en tête bien sûr la
démission de Nicolas hullo mais le vert
même si ça pouvait s'apparenter à une
sorte de allez greenwhing généralis
c'était au moins la couleur à la mode
c'était un slogan très populaire et
d'ailleurs et bien on a vu aussi que ça
s'est concrétisé puisqu'en 2019 les
écologistes avaient créé la surprise aux
élections européennes jusqu'à devenir la
4e force au Parlement européen et ça
vous nous dites c'était hier oui vous
vous rappelez le covid tout le monde
fantasmé sur le monde d'après plus
solidaire plus généreux plus écolo plus
rural enfin voilà il y avait tout tous
les bienfaits dans le monde d'après bah
non le monde d'après maintenant on est
en plein dedans et on a quand même
l'impression d'avoir pris la machine à
remonter le temps par exemple si on
regarde certains mots du gouvernement
français nous devons sortir de
l'écologie punitive pour être dans une
écologie des solution ça ce sont les
mots de la porte-parole du gouvernement
Prisc tevno la semaine dernière après
l'abandon du plan écito he le lendemain
elle faisait le service aprèsvente les
mots ils sont choisis l'écologie
punitive c'est une expression des années
2000 qu'on avait entendu dans la bouche
de Claude Allègre un climatosceptique en
chef une expression qui est à nouveau
très en vogue surtout à droite aussi
chez les chasseurs chez les industriels
les mots aussi ont été repris
entre-temps en 2014 par Segolen Royal
quand elle étaé ministre de
l'Environnement et quand elle a fini par
enterrer l'écotaxe face au bonnet rouge
autre-temps et bien nouvelle crainte de
Jacquerie on emploie les mêmes mots donc
face aux agriculteurs qui hasard
vestimentaire se sont pour certains
dénommés les bonnets jaunes en signe de
raliment et dans toute l'Europe
désormais les dirigeants politiques se
disent que affichés de façon hyper
volontariste qu'on lutte pour
l'environnement c'est pas tout à fait
rentable politiquement surtout à
l'approche des élections et donc dans
cette partie de notre débat on se
projette un peu vers ces élections
européenne du mois de de juin on est
quoi un peu à front renversé oui on l'a
expliqué hein si vous aimez le verre bah
vous le dites aujourd'hui pas trop fort
c'est ce qu'on voit avec ce qu' a dit
ursela van derlen qui bien d'un côté dit
assez fort qu'elle abandonne et bien les
objectifs sur les pesticides pour 2030
message signal pour les agriculteurs et
puis elle maintient quand même cet
objectif à la fois très ambitieux une
baisse nette de 90 % des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre mais avec un
horizon quand même assez lointain 2040
et puis Audrey l'a expliqué sans trop
nous dire les moyens pour y arriver tout
2040 pour nomopolitique c'est voilàs
loin c'est une promesse sur un horizon
qui ne vous engage pas quand vous êtes
un homme politique les mandats
politiques bien sûr c'est du temps court
les politiques publiques c'est du temps
long et entre les deux on observe et
bien un décalage horaire qui soutend ce
principe jamais démenti en inaction
politique pourquoi FA faire aujourd'hui
ce qui peut-être reporté à demain merci
beaucoup Tam je voudrais qu'on se
projette un peu sur les les les leviers
que l'Union européenne peut activer
c'est notre question centrale que fait
l'Europe en matière de transition
écologique Camille dear peut-être que
l'une des solutions vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer tout à l'heure pour emmener le
plus grand nombre autour de ces de ces
objectifs environnementaux est-ce que
c'est l'emprunt tiens est-ce qu'il faut
créer de la dette européenne un peu
comme on l'a fait au moment de la crise
sanitaire au moment du covid en tout cas
de plus en plus de voix s'élèvent en la
faveur d'un nouvel emprunt européen
notamment Christine Lagarde la
présidente de la Banque centrale
européenne et ses équipes qui ont fait
un papier là-dessus mais d'autres centre
de réflexion comme comme le mien
également appelons à avoir un un nouvel
emprunt européen pour financer cette
ambition énergie climat bien sûr parce
que le problème de de la transition
c'est que c'est une transition qui est
intensive en capital euh donc qui va
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça ça veut
dire que ça représente des coûts
d'investissement très élevés et il y a
pas beaucoup de retours sur
investissement
et lentement mais néanmoins les coûts
d'utilisation par exemple d'une centrale
solaire sont quasi nuls donc une fois
qu'on a construit cette centrale solaire
on est tranquille et c'est le cas pour
la plupart des technologies propres et
donc on fait face aujourd'hui à un mur
d'investissement qui nécessite de
changer de braquet tant sur le plan
financement privé mais aussi financement
public ou c'est le retour sur
investisement enfin sauf si on intègre
ce qu'on peut appeler les externalités
négatives ou les conséquences négatives
de l'inaction qui sont les catastrophes
avec ce que ça peut coûter et et là
évidemment on est on est en dizaines ou
en centaines de de milliards d'euros et
il a y a donc il y a le levier de de la
dette je reste avec vous tiens quand
même c'est compliqué pour parce que
Emmanuel Macron l'avait proposé je crois
que c'était à Davos il y a il y a un peu
près un mois lever un des eurobond un
emprunt européen alors il parlait pas de
la transition écologique il parlait
plutôt de l'énergie de la défense mais
bon ça peut marcher aussi pour la
transition écologique sauf qu'il faut le
faire accepter au pays qu'on appelle les
frugos totalement et et même avant cela
il faudrait résoudre une psbas Autriche
danemarque Suède voilà euh Allemagne euh
mais pour cela il faudrait résoudre une
la question épineuse de la façon dont on
rembourse le premier emprunt que l'on a
contracté pour résoudre la crise du
covid et ça donc ça s'appelle les
ressources propres de l'Union européenne
donc c'est-à-dire les les recettes du
budget il faut créer de nouvelles
recettes et ça va être aussi un grand
enjeu et à mon avis un make or break du
pacte vert européen pour le prochain
mandat parce que sans financement
additionnel on risque d'avoir non
seulement des ambitions au niveau
national qui se réduisent à pot de
chagrin mais également un manque de
coordination de ces politiques
nationales au niveau européen poier
est-ce qu'il y a aussi levier de la de
l'information c'estd que est-ce qu'on
sait suffisamment nous citoyens européen
ce que l'Europe a pu faire en matière de
transition environnementale ce qui a
déjà été mis en place qui fonctionne ce
qui est réussi en quelque sorte ça c'est
le drame du projet européen c'est que je
pense les citoyens sont pas au courant
du tout de ce qui se passe il y a
quelques mesure très très médiatique
qu'on pu percer ça et là comme
l'interdiction des véhicules thermiques
à 2035 mais globalement moi c'est vrai
que ça me fait toujours un peu de peine
de me rendre compte qu'on parle du Green
Deal quand il y a un renoncement après
tout ce qu'on a enfin je dis après tout
ce qui a été fait c'est des centaines de
mesures et d'objectifs nouveaux qu' on
été qu' on été porté donc oui il y a un
déficit d'information sur sur la le
projet européen ça c'est ça c'est sûr
après toutes ces mesures elles vont
arriver dans le débat public d'ici
quelques mois en France et dans les
autres pays et c'est toujours un peu
drôle d'ailleurs de voir qu'on a des des
des ministres qui qui qui portent des
projets qui se revendiquent ambitieux
alors qu'en fait ils transpos il
transpose des choses qui ont été adopté
il y a 18 mois à Bruxelles et qui ont
été défendus parfois voilà fermement
durement par les eurodéputés on
reconnaît pas du tout c'est leur travail
quoi ça c'est sûr oui mais avec
effectivement notamment si on vous
l'avez évoqué je crois tout à l'heure
mais la question de des entreprises des
industries c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises qui sont en train de
prendre ce virage alors c'est plus
facile quand on crée une start-up parce
qu'on peut cocher toutes les cases c'est
c'est beaucoup plus difficile quand on
quand c'est une entreprise qui a un
siècle d'existance et qu'il faut qui
doit changer de modèle économique mais
est-ce qu'elle l'aurait fait sans
l'aiguillon européen vous voyez ce que
je veux dire les entreprises européennes
oui bah c'est-à-dire en fait ça dépend
celles qui sont sur le marché mondial je
crois qu'elles ont déjà plus le choix
heinou mais après de toute façon c'est
toujours enfin jeux dire mais c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites parce que
elles ont plus le choix mais sauf qu'on
peut dire aussi aujourd'hui ça coûte
cher il faut investir donc c'est plus un
boulet que un
argument d'efficacité ou de rentabilité
oui après enfin je pense que quand on
est un ou une dirigeant d'entreprise il
faut voir à plus long terme et la
transition écologique elle est rentable
à long terme et puis de toute façon
c'est assez inéluctable donc je je pense
que de de ce point de vue là les
industries sont il y en a même qui sont
demandeuses en fait parce que elles ont
besoin de se cadre pour y aller elles
ont besoin aussi des fois d'aide pour se
pour se lancer donc je je je pense que
en fait ça ça ça va rouler quoi ça do en
tout cas on on a pas vraiment le choix
ça c'est ça c'est évident je revient aux
agriculteurs français on essaie toujours
dans ce débat d'être à la fois sur la
généralité de ce pacte vert et puis sur
la la la crise agricole vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure à quel point les
les agriculteurs français et européens
sont dépendants de des des fonds de la
la politique agricole commune un exemple
de réaction 22 janvier dernier donc on
est encore en pleine crise agricole ici
en France et le président de la FNSEA
sort d'une réunion à Matignon voici ce
qui dit de l'Europe de l'Union
européenne on a dit très clairement au
Premier ministre que l'Europe c'était le
cas don lequel on voulait agir que cette
Europe elle nous questionnait mais
qu'elle restait pour nous le cas dans
lequel ça devait se passer et donc cette
Europe on y tient mais on a besoin aussi
de la remettre en question parce que la
manière très administrative de l'affaire
n'est plus comprise par les par les
agriculteurs on peut pas avoir des dates
qui régentent nos actions dans nos dans
nos champs on peut pas avoir des
obligations de réimplanter des prairies
quand on a plus d'animaux enfin autant
de choses qui paraissent absolument un
non sens ARD L peut-être qu'il faut
faire un peu de pédagogie rappeler ce
que pèse le la la politique agricole
commune dans le budget de de l'Union
européenne et puis surtout à quel point
cet argent est vital pour les
agriculteurs en France et pas seulement
c'est c'est puisqu'on parlait des des
questions budgétaires parmi les levier
que possède l'Europe il y a les dépenses
de la politique agricole commune qui qui
ont été très importantes qui sont moins
j'ai pas les pourcentages en tête je
m'en excuse mais en tout cas ça reste
des masses considérables et euh c'est le
premier budget euh de de l'Union
européenne budget de la et ce qui me
semble emblématique et problématique de
cette de de cette difficulté justement
de de de de d'appliquer cette transition
c'est que finalement en dans en matière
agricole l'argent on en a parce que ce
budget il existe et c'est ce budget
d'aide il il afflue vers les les les
milieux agricole mais quand on a essayé
parce que c'est une question qu'on a
depuis un certain temps de le verdir euh
on s'est heurté euh aux mêmes
oppositions euh qu'on a aujourd'hui dans
euh une le syndicalisme conservateur
c'est-à-dire le refus euh de de de de
faire des choix mais des choix qui sont
difficiles parce qu'il il ils obligent à
transférer une partie de l'argent qui va
vers les grosses exploitations qui sont
tournées vers l'exportation pour les
mettre vers des petites exploitations
qui elles sont euh beaucoup plus aptes à
rentrer dans les enjeux de la transition
environnementale donc là il y a des
choix politiques mais qui n'ont pas été
faits pour ça que moi je suis pas
vraiment surpris ce qu'on n' pas réussi
à faire en tout cas pour l'agriculture
c'est-à-dire de verdir la politique
agricole commune ben on n'arrive pas à
verdir la politique européenne parce que
il y a des des intérêts qui sont en jeu
et qui posent voilà des à mon sens des
questions très très importantes parce
que euh on a cette question est-ce que
on peut fonctionner euh seulement à
travers tous pareil au sein de l'Europe
on ne pas se faire concurrence mais il y
a la question du du commerce
international euh une grande partie de
l'argent européen sert à financer des
exploitation qui exportent euh des
produits donc on et qui soutiennent donc
qui y compris en utilisant des produits
et cetera donc il faut repenser en fait
très largement le le rapport à la
production agricole et ces empreintes là
mais moi j'ai un peu ce sentiment je
suis pas spécialiste hein de de la
politique agricole commune donc je je
m'avance peut-être un petit peu mais
j'ai j'ai ce sentiment malgré tout que
voilà il y a clairement un manque de
volonté politique pour toutes les
raisons qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure et
on parle dans dans ce débat du du du
yatus qui peut y avoir entre les
décisions prises par la Commission
européenne et puis le ressenti des des
citoyens et notamment des consommateurs
je reprends un des chiffres qui était
donnés sur l'objectif les objectifs du
du Green Deal du pacte vert au niveau
agriculture exploiter 25 % des terres
agricoles en bio d'ici à 2030 sauf que
car on est aujourd'hui dans une période
on peut le regretter mais c'est c'est
comme ça avec l'inflation où le le bio
est en train de de de je sais pas quel
terme prendre un bouillon quoi c'est
c'est très difficile pour les exploitant
bio les les les les les surfaces de
vente bio donc les consommateurs
français mais je pense que c'est pas
seulement en France sont en train on
espère peut-être que c'est conjoncturel
mais de s'en détourn
ouais bah c'est c'est donc donc là aussi
on est au princip un principe de réalité
qui est compliqué quand même pour moi ça
découle toujours une fois de plus de
politique publique et de la façon don
quand on les met en œuvre le le le le
bio les aides au bio ont été réduites
cette année en France ça paraît fou
quand même quoi et donc ça veut dire il
faut le subventionner encore plus c'est
çaah oui bah c'està dire encore plus il
faut subventionner suffisamment
peut-être en subventionnant légèrement
moins l'agriculture exportatrice et
chargée de pesticides il y a des
arbitrages à faire comme comme dit
Monsieur lin de l'argent il y en a la
PAC c'est 9 milliards 9 milliards en
France on peut réallouer un petit peu de
l'enveloppe c'est des rapports de force
c'est des rapports de force politiques
et desces de des rapports de force
économique parce que les les grands
groupes agro-industriels dont le
président de la FNSA est un bon exemple
il peut parler de verdir ses prairies
ben voilà c'est c'est ça qui pèse dans
dans le le le les exportations et dans
la représentation de la puissance
agricole française et c'est c'est
peut-être ce modèle là qu'il faut
interroger je dis pas qu'il faut le
supprimer mais il faut l'interroger
alors autre réaction à à cette annonce
par ursela Van derlen de de la pause
c'est pas totalement enfin la pause
c'est que on va voir ce qui se passe
après les élections européennes mais sur
le le le retrait des des des pesticides
celle de Cyriel châelin c'était tiens ce
matin sur notre antenne c'est la
présidente du groupe Europe Écologie les
vers à l'Assemblée nationale voici ce
qu'elle nous dit sur pesticides et
rendement agricole regardez je voulais
faire le lien entre le revenu et la
question des pesticides parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui on a une expérimentation
dans les deux sèbres sur des centaines
sur des milliers par pardon sur des
milliers d'hectares sur des milliers
d'hectares où on a justement appliqué le
plan écophyo c'està dire qu'on a réduit
de 50 % l'utilisation des pesticides
donc aujourd'hui on sait ce que ça donne
et bien la vérité c'est qu'il y a pas eu
de baisse de rendement ça c'est la
première chose c'està dire que quand on
baisse de 50 % l'utilisation des
pesticides il y a pas eu de baisse de
rendement et la deuxième chose c'est que
comme on achète moins au début de
pesticides et que ça un coût et bien en
fait par hectare c'est 200 € de plus
pour les agriculteurs ça veut dire que
si un agriculteur a 100 hactares
de de culture ça lui fait 20000 € de
plus par an vous agriculteurs c'est qu'
il se trompe visiblement c'est que je
dis que le gouvernement je dis que le
gouvernement se trompe et en fait a pris
une décision qui lui paraissait facile
mais qu' ne répond en rien à la demande
des agriculteurs ARD c'est ce que nous
dit Chatelin c'est intéressant sauf que
c'est pas exactement ce qu'on a entendu
dans la bouche de nombreux agriculteurs
qui étaient sur les barrages donc qui
tjour la difficulté j'ai j'ai une
comment une tendance à penser qu'il faut
un peu faire confiance au voilà au au
aux scientifiques et au à ces
expérimentations là il y a il y a un
vrai débat et et le ressenti réel
d'agriculteurs qui sont dans la
difficulté voilà nous disent on n' pas
vraiment d'alternative et ça nous
demande beaucoup plus d'heur de travail
pour un rendement similair il y a des il
y a des alternatives mais je crois qu'on
est tous sur la même longueur d'onde ces
alternatives elles ont un coût
économique elles ont un coût social euh
qu'il faut prendre en compte et il est
évident que ce qui choque les
agriculteurs c'est qu'ils ont le
sentiment que on leur empose en haut
d'un un modèle de transformation qui a
des conséquences radicales mais qu'on ne
leur donne pas les moyens de le mettre
en œuvre on ne compense pas on oublie et
je prends souvent cet exemple que la
phase précédente de transformation de
l'agriculture dans les années 60 qui a
permis de transformer l'agriculture en
ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui on s'en plain elle a été
fait à grand coup de d'investissement
massif par l'Europe par l'État qui
finançait les hangars les machines à
traire les tracteurs on a mis un argent
là on a un pas en avant quasiment aussi
important pas dans la même direction
mais il faut que la société accepte que
l'État finance et que les consommateurs
payent parce que non mais ne pas suivent
mais paye parce que ce qu'on oublie
aussi souvent que c'est que cette
agriculture qu'on nous vend comme un
modèle de réussite subventionné elle a
été aussi faite pour coûter le moins
cher possible au consommateurs il faut
aussi que les consommateurs que la
société comprenne que oui mais quand on
n pas eu d'augmentation de salaire et
qu'on a du mal à boucler les fins de
mois ça tient pas votre argument ça
tient pas si ça tient ça tient parce que
il y a 100 ans on consacrait 40 % de son
budget à l'alimentation aujourd'hui on
en consacre 5 % est-ce que les 4 % qu'on
y consacre pas on le consacre à des
choses essentielles je vais prendre un
exemple stupide celui son téléphone
portable je désolé la surconsommation
d'un nombre de de consommation elle a
fait elle fait oublier que l'enjeu
agricole est important et quand on sait
que pardon et quand on sait que derrière
ça il y a la destruction des sols il y a
la pollution de l'eau et il y a la mise
en cause des des personnes qui
travaillent dans l'agriculture des
paysans on peut se dire il faut
peut-être faire quelque chose c'est pour
ça que c'est passionnant c'est vraiment
un modèle de société sur lequel on on se
questionne merci beaucoup merci à à
toutes et à tous d'avoir participé à ce
déb je vous dis à lundi pour un nouveau
numéro de sens publicque
18h22h et puis notez que demain Orian
mansini reçoit le chef étoilet tiré Marx
qui est également le le président
confédéral de l'Union des des métiers de
l'hôtellerie ça parlera aussi
alimentation tiens sur bonne
soirée